-Hi, Louie.
-How are you?
-Good. How are you?
-How drunk were you?
-I was really drunk.
-It was such a good --
-Yeah, she was wonderful, right?
Such a good sport.
-Such a good sport about it.
-Yeah.
-That's so nice.
You know, I always thought
they made the "Chucky" thing
after me.
-Oh, really?
-I used to think that.
I'd go,
"That looks just like me."
[ Laughter ]
-And you never got any cas
for it?
-I got nothing.
-Are you well, though?
Are you doing good?
-I'm great.
-Yeah.
-I'm having so much fun.
I love coming to New York.
-All right, do you --
Now, you live in Las Vegas
So I'm assuming you drive there.
-I don't drive anywhere,
first of all.
-Okay, got you.
-I just take Lyft.
-Because I like the name.
-Yeah, yeah, it's nice.
It's a good name.
-A Lyft -- "Louie, a Lyft is
gonna pick you up."
Thank God.
[ Laughter ]
Right? I just --
They're really nice people
-And do you enjoy -- do you like
driving around New York?
-Well, I'm being driven around
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Because I'm a big shot.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's nice
when someone drives you.
-Yeah, of course.
-Yeah.
And then but you --
I am laid back.
You have to get into
the pace of the city.
-Yes, it's a different place
-Like, after I'm in the car half
hour, I'm saying to the driver
"Run him down. He shouldn't be
going across there."
[ Laughter ]
Do you ever get --
I mean, it's wrong.
I know. I don't really want hi
to do it, but...
[ Laughter ]
Because people will dart here.
-There's darters, yeah.
-They will just go.
-Yeah.
-And you go, "You're gonna die!"
[ Laughter ]
They never do.
-People are impatient here
-Yes.
-More patient than Las Vegas
-Listen, in Vegas, you know --
Well, in Vegas,
they're just interested
in trying to find
the money they lost.
-Yeah, yeah. Of course.
-Or just have fun.
-Sure, they're there
to have fun. Right.
-They came there
just to have fun.
And here,
people are going places.
And I'm at a different pace.
I'm a loper.
-Yeah.
-I'm like,
"Yeah, I'll get there."
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-And people are constantly
going by me -- "Get going!
You know, and I go, "Shut up."
[ Laughter ]
But I was --
This is the best one.
I'm in the revolving door thing,
which I'm always thrilled
when I can get in there
and push that thing.
I don't know why.
-Yeah, yeah.
-It's like a 2-year-old thing.
-It's great.
-"Let me go in! Let me go in!"
I'm in there.
A woman comes in behind me
out coming from the other way.
Obviously, I'm going too slow.
-Yeah.
-So she goes, looks,
and pushes it faster.
Then I just locked it up.
[ Laughter ]
She was furious.
She goes, "Let go!"
I go, "What? Let go of what?
"Stop it!" You know?
And it was just so much fun.
Oh, it was so much fun.
-I want to talk about
season four of "Baskets."
-Yes.
-So great.
-So much fun.
-You're basing this
off your mother.
-I am.
-And I know you guys
were really close.
-Very, very close.
-You guys were on television
together once.
-Oh, yes.
-This is local television.
-Oh, my God.
-I mean, look at you two.
-Look at that.
-That is a mother and son
if I ever saw one.
-Is that cool or what?
That was a Mother's Day specia
on local with, you know,
local people with their moms
and I happened to be on it
-And did she have fun?
-She was a little nervous.
I was surprised.
-And was she nervous
in real life?
Was she a confident person tha
just in front of the camera --
-Yeah, yeah.
She was pretty confident.
But she was a shy --
There was a shy part of her.
-Gotcha.
-Unlike Christine,
who's a bull in a china shop
-She is a bull in a china shop
The clip we just saw, obviousl
you're dealing with a --
you're shooting with cats.
-Do like doing
acting with animals?
-Listen, I wish I got treate
like the animals do.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
It is a good situation?
-There's, like, four handler
per animal.
They're bringing them in.
And then they'll say to me
"Now, she or he doesn't like i
you scratch under their chin."
So I'm right away --
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You can't tell me stuff
like that.
[ Laughter ]
I say, "I don't like it
when you do this to me."
[ Laughter ]
No, it was fun,
and they're great cats,
and it was a lot of fun, and
the character loves her cats
And, you know, so it's good.
-That's good.
I also want to ask -- you know
people tell you not to scratch
cats a certain way.
I know people
are trying to tell you
and get you to eat
healthier foods.
-You know, this is what happen
to you when you're fat.
And you other fat people kno
what I'm talking about.
[ Laughter ]
They get in your business.
They start, you know --
they'll bring --
like, last time
I was in Chicago,
they brought me books
in a bag -- how to not die
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-One of the books was
"How to Not Die."
And then the next one was
a "How to Not Die" cookbook.
[ Laughter ]
So I'm hoping I can get throug
the first book.
So that I can know
how to cook the food.
And then, they brought -- they
said, "We make these cookies
There's dates in them.
They're delicious.
It's like a regular cookie
They're sweet.
They're delicious."
And you open the bag,
and they're wet.
[ Laughter ]
Have you ever had that?
-Yeah, I know what
you're talking about.
-Where you just go,
"Oh, wet cookie! Oh!"
[ Laughter ]
Wet, there's something -- an
you take a bite out of courtes
because they're right ther
staring at you.
"Oh, geez," you know.
And you're moving it aroun
in your mouth.
[ Laughter ]
I cannot wait to spit
the wet cookie out.
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't think about how
distressing it is
to reach into a bag
and touch anything wet.
-Wet, wet cookies.
-Yeah.
-I'm looking for,
you know, a date cookie.
You know?
-Yeah.
-Baked -- not baked, obviously
just wet.
-Yeah.
-They just formed them,
smashed them down,
and threw them in the bag.
-Yeah, these are not cookies
that were baked at all.
These were just,
like, manhandled.
-A lesson -- here's how much o
a food addict I am.
I eventually ate
all those cookies.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, somebody made them.
So that's very nice.
Louie Anderson, everybody.